okay so many of you are aware that it is
not just cognitive decline that is a
possibility to explain Donald Trump's
bizarre behavior but increasingly the
explanation we are seeing get more and
more traction is amphetamine use or
better said abuse we've seen Trump's
upper and downer modes two very
different Trump's depending on what's
going on and we don't know exactly
what's going on sometimes high energy
sweaty red adjutant corresponding with
the upper phase and then the slow
slurring depressed Trump who often has
trouble making sense of the speech
that's on his prompter or on paper in
front of him which corresponds with more
of a coming down from uppers phase we've
also seen pictures of Donald Trump's
Trump Tower desk stuffed with boxes of
sudafed and specifically a version of
sudafed that's not sold in the United
States and it is more sudafed than one
person can even legally buy at a time in
the United States now sudafed can be
crushed up and snorted like adderall can
it can be taken by mouth publicly Trump
often shows signs and symptoms of
amphetamine abuse some examples include
sounding stuffed-up whenever he's in
downer mode has Donald Trump had a cold
for the last three years I guess it's
possible but it is common that sudafed
for example is a nasal decongestant it
can cause a rebound congestion effect
where it wears off especially when
you're taking recreational amounts as we
see that Donald Trump does this often
and constantly sounds stuffed up Trump
in fact sounded stuffed up during the
press conference with Turkish president
arrow on last week and I'm gonna get to
that momentarily another effect of that
rebound congestion after you start
coming down from the uppers is that you
sniff a lot which Donald Trump does all
the time as you may have seen
compilation videos of Trump speaking and
and sniffing below between phrases as I
am sort of demonstrating for you right
now Trump also appearing to have trouble
speaking when in downer mode sometimes
it seems as though his dentures are
loose but remember based on his medical
from doesn't wear dentures rich guys
tend not to wear dentures but to get
medical dental implants so that's not an
explanation it just so happens though
that dry mouth is a symptom of
amphetamine abuse be it adderall or
sudafed this is what it sounds like when
Trump is in that mode let us rethink old
assumptions and open our hearts and
minds to possible and possibilities and
finally I asked the leaders of the
region political and religious Israeli
and Palestinian Jewish and Christian and
Muslim to join us in the noble quest for
lasting peace thank you god bless you
god bless Israel God bless the
Palestinians and God bless the United
States thank you very much there it is
and again if you don't believe Trump
wears dentures which we've been told he
doesn't and rich people tend not to wear
them dry mouth makes a lot more sense
and it just so happens that it's another
symptom of methamphetamine of
amphetamine abuse so that's all the
stuff we knew the new thing is that I
was contacted by an anesthesiologist
over the weekend who said David I was
looking at pictures and video of Donald
Trump at last week's press conference
with the Turkish president air Dewan
there were bright lights on them it was
a very brightly lit room and in a normal
situation pupils would be relatively
contracted during that situation but
Donald Trump has extremely dilated
pupils when you look closely at him from
this press conference now of course in a
bright room pupils should contract if
something is not keeping them dilated as
we know stimulants increase the
concentration of norepinephrine in the
brain which keeps the pupils stuck in
that open position an anesthesiologist
looked at this and wrote to me when I
see this I see someone who is clearly on
some kind of stimulant now you also saw
Trump blinking a lot and squinting which
would be exactly what you do if you're
in a bright room and your pupils aren't
contracting when you go to the eye
doctor as I recently did and you get the
drops to dilate your pupils so that the
doctor can look in at the back of the
eye
when you get out and go outside if
you're not wearing very dark sunglasses
it exists extremely uncomfortable so do
we know for sure we don't but it's all
shaping up pretty clearly I want to hear
from you
the slurred speech dry mouth dilated
pupils upper downer Trump sniffing and
congestion another known rebound effect
of using too much nasal decongestant let
me know what you think I want to hear
from you send me a tweet on Twitter at D
Pakman leave a reply to the YouTube clip
or the Facebook video clip wherever you
are watching I want to hear from you
what do you think is going on I must
have gotten three or four dozen emails
over the weekend about Donald Trump
going to the hospital for a multi-hour
unplanned visit it wasn't on his
schedule
with speculation just running rampant
about what this is related to and some
of the people who emailed me about this
we're speculating that maybe this is
related to Trump's cognitive decline but
you don't get rushed to a hospital
unexpectedly for cognitive decline you
schedule a meeting with a neurologist
and you get tested so I don't believe
that that's what this is about now the
White House in retrospect is saying that
these were tests related to Trump's
20/20 annual physical but it really
doesn't make sense because again it
wasn't untrust schedule and the hospital
didn't know Trump was coming and I'll
get to that later what is very clear is
that the White House doesn't seem to be
telling the truth about this the more
they speak the more it sounds odd
because Trump's press secretary said
Trump is quote anticipating a very busy
2020 and therefore wanted to take
advantage of a quote free weekend in
Washington to just get ahead on some
portions of his routine checkup not
scheduled until next year doesn't really
make much sense and I'll tell you why in
a second Donald Trump also tweeting
quote visited a great family of a young
man under major surgery at the amazing
Walter Reed Medical Center those are
truly some of the best doctors in the
world also began phase one of my yearly
physical
everything good great actually will
complete next year now why would we
doubt this there are many reasons first
showing up unexpectedly in November of
2019 for parts of a physical not
scheduled until 2020 when Trump's past
physicals have just lasted for hours
and he was there for two hours this time
it just doesn't really make any sense
and then you add to this that Trump just
had a physical nine months ago
it also doesn't make sense that he would
be rushing in months early to get
another physical or at least part of one
done add to this that Walter Reed
Hospital says we didn't know Trump was
coming he was not scheduled to be here
if you're coming in for two hours of
tests and you're the president you can
be damn sure that the hospital knows
that you're coming Karen Tumulty has a
good piece in The Washington Post which
should guide us which explains that even
when the White House's explanations make
sense or appear to make sense they are
very often lies they lie all the time
they lie about everything even
insignificant things when the White
House's explanation does not make sense
you can be almost certain that it's a
lie and here the explanation makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever and in
fact claims around Donald Trump's health
haven't made sense for a very long time
remember claiming that he is six foot
three when Obama is 6 1 and in any
picture of them together Trump is
clearly shorter than Barack Obama that
never made sense but it was useful to
try to have numbers on paper that make
Trump just short of obese rather than
obese the letter from Trump's old doctor
Herald Bornstein that Trump would be the
healthiest president ever when he was at
the time I believe 70 or 71 eats food
constantly arguably obese if not
borderline obese and Bornstein of course
hadn't examined any other presidents how
could Harold Bornstein say Trump would
be the healthiest president ever it
didn't make sense you would have to be
very dim to believe that Donald Trump
not scheduled for medical exams until
next year would say hey you know what
I'm not golfing this weekend what the
hell let's go do two hours of testing at
Walter Reed even though they have no
idea that I'm coming there is no chance
that that's the real explanation now my
mere speculation is that Trump went in
for something like chest pain or
something along those lines possibly a
panic attack this is the type of thing
where someone feels as though they can't
breathe and their chest hurts they go in
they
a workup done doctors check to see if
you've had a heart attack and very often
they come out and say you didn't have a
heart attack it seems that this was a
panic attack Trump is not a healthy guy
he doesn't exercise he's overweight and
nearly to the point of obesity or
obesity depending on what numbers you
believe he eats terribly he's 73 years
old at some point one would imagine that
that would have repercussions if I had
to bet I would say panic or anxiety
related chest pain I don't blame the guy
things are not going well the walls
closing in Roger stone indicted on seven
counts impeachment inquiry another loss
in Louisiana things not looking good for
Trump that is my best guess and it is
merely a guest last thought if Trump
does abuse uppers amphetamines as it
increasingly seems that he does and
we're going to talk about that
momentarily those can make someone feel
like they are having a heart attack and
it wouldn't be remotely surprising if it
was related if indeed that is what
Donald Trump is doing of course Trump
not seen publicly or by the White House
press corps other than when he left the
hospital as of this recording of the
segment up until now
tweeting certainly tweeting non-stop but
also not seen publicly in any kind of
capacity we will see if we ever learn
the truth with the Trump administration
very often we never do
we're later going to talk about what
might have landed president Trump in the
hospital for an unscheduled visit and
we're going to talk about many of the
things in fact which would likely have
caused stress over the weekend because
quite frankly it was a very stressful
couple of days for Donald Trump during
the second day of the impeachment
hearings on Friday with Murray
Jovanovic clothes stove Roger stone a
close Trump advisor Roger stone and
close Trump ally Roger stone was found
guilty on all seven counts with which he
was charged and Trump absolutely
exploded afterwards now as a reminder
please review my interview with Roger
stone from I guess it must be about a
year and a half ago at this point or
longer where Roger stone insisted he did
nothing wrong no one did anything wrong
and it turns out he may not
been honest with me during that
interview check that out because Roger
stone was found guilty on seven counts
including lying to Congress witness
tampering obstruction of justice of the
Russia probe into Donald Trump he is
Trump aide and advisor number six to be
convicted so far so the immediate
question is how much time might Roger
stone end up doing in prison the answer
on paper is that he could end up with up
to 20 years although if I had to bet and
I am NOT a betting man I would bet that
Roger stone gets nothing close to twenty
years and then of course we will talk
about pardon the possibilities
momentarily adding to the hijinks of the
stone guilty verdict there's this other
Trump aide named Michael Caputo who was
in the courtroom at the time of the
verdicts read out and he had to be
removed from the courtroom because when
the verdict was read he just turned
around and turned his back on the jury
extraordinarily childish but again these
are the types of people that Donald
Trump has around him in a variety of
different capacities and then of course
Trump exploding on Twitter and why
wouldn't he if stone were to turn on
Trump it could be very very bad for the
president although there's no indication
at this point in time that stone plans
to turn on Trump for the purposes of a
lighter sentence and why would he if he
expects or anticipates that he will be
pardoned by Donald Trump but we will get
to that Trump first tweeting but but but
but what about all the people that I
want put in jail saying quote so they
now convict Roger stone of lying and
want to jail him for many years to come
well what about crooked Hillary Comey
struck page McCabe Brennan clapper
shifty Schiff and Nellie Steele and all
of the others including even Muller
himself didn't they lie a double
standard like never seen before in the
history of our country understand that
the President of the United States is
publicly saying he wants to a put the
legally appointed special counsel who
investigated him
in prison Trump believes on the one hand
I guess that molar wrote a report that
completely exonerates him remember Trump
went around the country claiming that
Robert Muller completely exonerated him
but then he also wants the person who
supposedly exonerated him imprisoned
authoritarian on one hand but also
completely incoherent on the other hand
and then of course you're still talking
about Hillary Donald
seriously and notably it's important
that Trump doesn't actually say in the
tweets Stone is innocent stone is not
guilty stone might be innocent he merely
says if you convict Roger stone for this
then you should really convict all of
these other people that I don't like
it's brazen authoritarian what about ISM
now let's discuss the pardon that's the
other topic here that deserves some
attention although it probably deserves
that it's its own exploration in a topic
in and of itself as usual the White
House is not even entertaining the idea
that Donald Trump may have signaled in
any direct or even indirect way that any
pardons would be incoming for anybody
who keeps their mouth shut
now we do have when it came to Paul
Manafort
there were allegations that the
possibility of a pardon had been
intimated through a number of different
channels I don't have anything
specifically about Roger stone here but
we do know that if you keep your mouth
shut and you don't turn on Trump and you
don't turn into someone who could
potentially put Trump in a precarious
position you may be rewarded with a
pardon when it is all said and done I
hope that Robert Muller truly deeply
just sincerely regrets not subpoenaing
Donald Trump and at least trying to
force him to show up in person because
he didn't do it and Muller is still
getting crushed by Trump what was the
big advantage again to not bringing
Trump in I guess it was that Muller said
well the policy of the Justice
Department is not to prosecute sitting
presidents so we decided not even to
subpoena Donald Trump arguably the
weakest decision of molars entire
investigation maybe of his entire career
because in the end he didn't do it he
let Trump off in in the weakest possible
way and Trump is still saying publicly
what about imprisoning Robert Muller
pardon we will see Roger stone
sentencing not scheduled until I believe
it's in the first week of February and
when that time comes we will see what
the guy ends up with I think it will be
far far short of the 20 year maximum
that he could hypothetically be
sentenced to let me know what you think
about the likely sentencing for Roger
stone let's talk about Donald Trump's
tax returns briefly the situation with
Donald Trump's tax returns is escalating
to the point where Donald Trump is now
effectively begging the Supreme Court to
hide his tax returns from investigators
and this is hilarious but it's also very
important in terms of what is quickly
becoming a battle really about the
separation of powers in the United
States and about checks and balances so
I'll catch you up and then we'll get to
the news investigators have a criminal
probe going into Donald Trump and his
businesses finances they've tried to
obtain Donald Trump's tax returns and
his business tax returns for this
investigation Trump tried to block it
multiple courts have already okayed it
the next step is the Supreme Court and
indeed Donald Trump has filed for an
appeal to the Supreme Court now what's
important with the Supreme Court is
they're not required to take the case at
all they're not required to review the
ruling of the lower court in this case
it's the second district court the
Supreme Court might decide we're not
going to take the case and in that
situation the lower court ruling would
stand which in this particular situation
is a ruling that says Trump has to
provide the tax returns to the
investigators importantly the Supreme
Court currently has two Trump selections
Neil Neil Gorsuch and the absolute
lunatic Brett Kavanaugh the Supreme
Court is going to announce in the next
few weeks if they will review the case
if they agree to review the case that
review probably will happen before the
2020 election now there is breaking news
on this the Supreme Court did yesterday
imposed an indefinite
a on the house of representatives demand
for president Trump's financial records
to give them time to figure out how to
handle the dispute until they decide
what is going to happen with this case
that case the other case related to
Donald Trump's taxes but this is a major
separation of powers case because if the
Supreme Court does take the case and
they decide you know what Trump does not
have to turn over his tax returns what
does that say about our checks and
balances the checks and balances in our
system what does it say about Donald
Trump's ability to or not to have to
obey prevailing laws it also relates to
this issue of Donald Trump's immunity
Trump's lawyers claim that Donald Trump
has immunity
not just from prosecution but even from
investigation that is a very loose
reading of any law that you can find and
a big piece of all of this is going to
come down to that because remember we
were told and even robert muller said at
the conclusion during his testimony and
and in the Moller report that he did not
take a position on whether Donald Trump
should be indicted on obstruction of
justice because it is the policy via
memo it has not been legally tested but
it is the policy via memo of the Justice
Department not to prosecute a sitting
president that's layer one we could we
could argue that we could debate that
there is this further position that
Donald Trump's lawyers are trying to
argue that Donald Trump's taxes and his
business taxes should not be provided to
investigators in New York why because
Donald Trump is immune even from
investigation and I have read no
seriously legal opinion that agrees with
that and then of course we go back to
the bigger picture on the merits anybody
working this hard to hide their tax
returns has something to hide that is
very very serious we don't have to go
through that once again I don't believe
that Donald Trump's taxes would expose
criminality although arguably double
accounting and one set of books for loan
purposes and one set of books for tax
purposes in New York State is
actually against the law I believe the
most likely scenario is that Donald
Trump would be exposed as not being as
wealthy as he claims to be
I believe that Donald Trump's shady
business dealings which are the subject
of much speculation with all sorts of
different countries could be Russia
Saudi Arabia and others would
potentially be exposed and it would be
both personally embarrassing to Trump
and also problematic for him I don't
know that it's a shoo-in that there's
actual criminality or at least
definitive criminality that would be
exposed by Trump's tax returns although
I certainly wouldn't rule it out and it
wouldn't come as a surprise given
everything that has got gone on so my
question is to you number one why do you
believe that Donald Trump has been
working so hard for so long to prevent
the release of his tax returns number
two what do you believe will ultimately
happen with this case and the release of
Trump's taxes will the Supreme Court
take the case let me know what you think
remember to get on the david pakman show
newsletter at david pakman.com on black
friday if you are on that newsletter you
will receive an email with a very
special discount code useful only on
black friday for a major membership
discount at the David Pakman show you
need only sign up for our newsletter at
david pakman.com we will take a quick
break
I have interesting video for you coming
up next we will talk about the schedule
for the show for the rest of the week
because there is a lot going on and a
very interesting voicemail still to play
for you let's focus in more on this
issue of how we're treating members of
the military right now
I'm truly sick of the current president
mocking and ridiculing members of the
military and just generally not being
good to people in the military the
latest is that Trump mocked Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander bin Minh in his first
public appearance since his hospital
visit specifically he mocked VIN Minh
for wearing his military uniform then he
also mocked last week's witness George
Kent for his bowtie take a look at this
I don't know him I don't know as he says
Lieutenant Colonel I understand somebody
had the misfortune of calling him mister
and he corrected them I never saw the
man I understand now he wears this
uniform when he goes in no I don't know
Vin de Minh at all what I do know is
that even he said that the transcript
was correct and if anybody reads the
transcripts I had two calls with the
president of Ukraine who by the way said
there was no pressure whatsoever there
was no anything they don't they probably
think they can't they probably can't
even understand what's going on with
this country but VIN Minh I watched him
for a little while this morning and I
think he I'm gonna let people make their
own determination but I don't know VIN
Minh I never heard of him I don't know
any of these people other than I have
seen one or two a couple of times
they're ambassadors but these are names
that are talking like Taylor like Kent
with the nice bowtie wonderful bowtie
maybe I'll get one for myself someday
I don't know Kent is I don't know who
Taylor is this is how you know their
beat in Trump's case I don't think he
actually has the attention span or the
cognitive capacity to sit through to
listen to to understand the witnesses
the devastating testimony from people
like Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh and
today from Gordon Sunland but that's
another story but look at the trend on
substance Republicans are unable to
refute the obvious bad acting of Trump
and the people around him with regard to
Ukraine and that will become even more
impossible after Gordon sunland's
testimony today and then we get to trump
who again is going after members of the
military despite claiming that he's all
about the troops attacking the late
Senator John McCain because he got
captured and tortured and Trump prefers
military heroes who don't get captured
attacking and fighting with the parents
of a soldier who lost his life as an
army captain serving the US military
implying that veterans with PTSD just
aren't strong enough as I mentioned
earlier calling all sorts of generals
who have actual knowledge and experience
clueless claiming he knows more than the
generals he knows more than the Intel
ian's community he knows more than
everybody who serves the u.s. in some
way shape or form claiming that he's
donating money to veterans to get a PR
benefit and then not actually donating
the money there's no limit to the
sickening buffoonery but it is so
acutely disrespectful to a group that
Trump said he would respect Trump said
he would support them but more
importantly this is a group forget about
Trump for a second cuz he'll eventually
be gone this is a group that Republicans
in Trump's party claim to respect and
support where are the Republicans on
Trump's constant and persistent
disregard and disdain for members of the
military like Lieutenant Colonel VIN
Minh why can't they say hey you know
what I don't think Trump should be
impeached but there's no evidence that
we should be a sailing Vinh man's
character the the attacks on him are not
based in any kind of fact and Donald
Trump needs to stop right away I would
like to see them come forward and say
that now as far as VIN moons uniform
this is not my area of expertise I was
under the impression that if you're an
active military member if you go to
court or government proceedings like
House of Representatives proceedings
you're supposed to wear your uniform I
was I mean I I'm going off the top of my
head if I'm wrong I am will gladly
correct myself but that's the impression
that I was under and I truly don't
understand where this is even coming
from and why not we're hearing pushback
by the way Trump you know criticized of
Inman there for correcting Devon Nunez
who called him mister and said actually
I go by lieutenant colonel we looked at
that video earlier on in the show and
it's extremely enjoyable I hope that you
will check it out because it is it's
something else
Devon Nunez getting visibly
uncomfortable when he's corrected by
Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh but Trump
again why are you going after members of
the military all the time and really
when you're under impeachment the focus
is what the witnesses were wearing
George Kent's bowtie and Alexander VIN
man's military uniform you know they've
lost or you know they simply don't even
understand what's going on when the
focus is what the witness is the
devastating witnesses to Trump's
narrative we're wearing clothes the
Trump found unusual or worth commenting
on these guys are pathetic the
impeachment hearings from last week
were not the fireworks that we had maybe
hoped for or thought there were going to
be last week if I had to really sum it
up I would say we got corroboration of a
lot of stuff we suspected and then we
had one new piece of information which
was about a phone call between the EU
ambassadors Gardens Sunland and Donald
Trump which took place while Sunland was
in a restaurant that phone call may have
been surveilled by Russian intelligence
we found out and Bill Taylor's staffer
overheard that phone call that call has
since been corroborated it happened
that's part of what we now have more
information relating to things change
this week yesterday's testimony was much
different and it was very devastating to
the Trump narrative now whether it will
do anything as another question we've
already discussed but let's talk about
the substance we had Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander VIN Minh credible clearly
trustworthy careful not to say more than
what he can defend with facts and
personal knowledge still they were
smearing an active duty member of the
military because they didn't like what
he said and we'll get to that a little
bit later every witness yesterday
confirmed a part of the case against
Trump Trump used foreign policy for his
re-election campaign benefit he used
military aid to try to get campaign
favors through getting Biden smeared it
was annexed or to
bribery yesterday we had Lieutenant
Colonel VIN Minh and Jennifer Williams
who are now firsthand witnesses to the
July 25 phone call remember Republicans
previously complaining everything's
hearsay nobody has first-hand knowledge
that changed yesterday I had previously
told you the July 25 phone call is not
the whole story you can't just look at
that to determine if there was bribery
that was likely the conclusion to a
story that started earlier with
negotiations and phone calls and emails
and we confirmed that today because
ambassador Gordon Sundlun showed up and
threw everyone under the bus the we were
live streaming and the chat tripled in
speed on our YouTube channel when
Sunland started speaking because we
didn't know if Sunland was gonna play
that I don't remember I plead the fifth
game or if he would show up and
effectively completely turn on the
President of the United States and he
turned big-time and Republicans panicked
and tried to mitigate what Sundlun said
but Sunland said everybody knew what was
going on there were emails involving the
National Security Council Rudy Giuliani
was having conversations and text
messages the president knew what was
going on
Sunland made clear that the idea that
you know maybe you could make the case
that something was implied but we don't
really know Sunland says and he has the
records to back it up everybody knew
what the deal was
this was money in exchange for smears
meeting in exchange for public press
conference about investigations Sunland
threw everyone under the bus so that is
devastating to Donald Trump Kurt Volker
amended prior testimony also in a way
that was damaging to Trump he says
listen I learned a lot more since my
initial testimony and I have much more
to say even Trump's supposedly strongest
witness Volcker said Biden's an
honorable man and we hold him in high
regard there's no basis to the
conspiracies that Trump has been pushing
so on the substance this has been
particularly today with Sunland
extraordinarily devastating meanwhile
all Republicans can try to do to slow it
down is be boring go into tangential
stories about hunter Biden or other
irrelevant details try to attack
character assassinate the witnesses and
the real problem and ultimately this is
why nothing may quote happen as we're
talking about in terms of making things
happen too many Trump supporters either
don't understand the severity of this
and maybe they never will or they have
actually fallen for the very weak
talking points of Republicans the goal
would be if even some of the trumpets
can see what's going on see what went
down and be pulled into the light by
each one of these hearings then it's a
good thing and will of course be
following all of them all of the live
streams at youtube.com slash the David
Pakman show
I told you last week that within minutes
of finishing my livestream of the first
day of Trump impeachment hearings CNN
filed a copyright claim on my six hour
live
dream which I spent all day producing
instantly taking the video offline
instantly cutting off views instantly
cutting off revenue to that video now I
reached out to CNN and I appealed the
claim and I said hey we didn't use one
damn second of CNN video please release
the claim and by the following morning
the claim had been released
despite being completely bogus we did
lose views and monetization for many
many hours during a key time that people
were interested in that video
sad but we moved on Friday I did another
six hour livestream and in addition to
that day's broadcast we did audience
questions on the stream the full hearing
so on and so forth and it happened again
but this time it's even worse this time
it wasn't just CNN that claimed revenue
and blocked the video
so did NBC News now as a reminder we did
commentary on the hearings using a
c-span feed of the impeachment hearings
House of Representatives proceedings are
funded by my tax dollars and your tax
dollars and c-span's broadcasts of house
proceedings are in the public domain we
did not use a single second of NBC
coverage nor CNN coverage and yet I get
an email from YouTube saying the david
pakman show impeachment hearing day two
has received acclaim from NBC News this
instantly became indistinguishable from
parody and we instantly lose the revenue
from the video we spent all day
producing now of course I immediately
appeal I email my YouTube rep I email
anyone I know and within a few hours
NBC releases the claim thank you so much
we can now monetize the video again and
within it must have been no more than
five minutes of NBC releasing the claim
I start getting emails from viewers
saying David your entire video of that
stream and your commentary has been
blocked by CNN on copyright grounds this
now has to be a parody right this can't
be real I'm sure someone just made a
Photoshop that may
it look like the video was taken down
but oh I checked my email and yes the
david pakman show impeachment day 2 has
now received a claim from CNN what and I
check and this time unlike with NBC
where we merely lost monetization CNN
has blocked the entire video so once
again I appeal I start emailing everyone
I know and eventually it was unblocked
this is not how this is supposed to work
now this time fortunately this is
actually getting attention reclaim the
net published an article called David
Pakman hit with NBC News Content ID
claim on YouTube video containing none
of their footage we're good for them
reclaim the net actually wrote about
what's going on where they say quote
YouTube's broken copyright system is at
it again
political commentator David Pakman
coverage of today's impeachment hearing
against President Trump was hit with a
Content ID claim from NBC News
despite the video containing none of
their footage now this is where it
starts to get interesting this article
in reclaim the net led to some lawyers
reaching out to me and of course as much
as they want to help this is not easy to
fight because this is how the system is
supposed to work this is an automatic
Content ID system that works for big
media against shows like mine and so
many others that you probably watch it
gives the benefit of the doubt to the
computerized algorithm that supports CNN
and NBC and others and it makes me the
little guy have to prove that I didn't
break the rules so again we're talking
to lawyers I'm seeing if we can fight
this in any more systematic way but in
the meantime we're just gonna keep doing
what we're doing keep signing up on our
website for memberships to make that
YouTube revenue as irrelevant as we can
a hundred and seventy-five people thank
you signed up for memberships since we
got hit last week and I so appreciate
you doing that let's keep it going david
pakman.com slash membership memberships
are really cheap I won't spend a lot of
time on this they really help us even if
you contribute 3 bucks a month by using
the coupon code half 19 which saves you
50% that 3 dollars a month is way way
way more than we make from any one
viewer on YouTube that I can assure you
any one viewer you know we make
fractions of a cent from on YouTube so
you were doing so much good please keep
doing it
I'll keep you posted about anything
legal that we can do or that we choose
to do but it is very very ugly and it is
unfortunately I mean listen all I can do
is we've got to do the streams that our
audience wants us to do these
impeachment hearings streams have gotten
six to seven thousand live concurrent
viewers for a six hour period that is a
really successful stream for us it is
highly engaging we get subscribers we
get members and super chat questions
we're gonna keep doing it and then if we
have to fight for the revenue once those
videos are archived I'm ready to do it
it sounds like we have people who are
willing to help us do it and we're gonna
try to fix the system if we can but if
we can't we will work within it and do
everything that we can to keep doing
this content and to keep providing the
commentary so that's where we are today
sadly it I know it seems satirical we
had this happen on Wednesday and then it
happens EE on Friday but it is what it
is I'll keep you informed about how it
continues